[Music]
the war on statues has opened up a brand
new front as we told you yesterday
activists in California are targeting a
statue of of all people President
William McKinley they claim his policies
have harmed Native Americans he
certainly won't be the last American
targeted this way Madison Flint is a
member of the Wyatt Tribal Council in
California and she joins us tonight
Madison thanks for coming on hi thank
you for having me it's pronounced a we
are quite big your I beg your pardon
well I stand corrected and informed so
of all the statues to prominent
Americans why does this statue offend
the weot tribe it offends the Weah
people because it the representation of
that era I don't know if you're familiar
with the Weah history but there they
were the ancestral people of the Arcada
territory where the McKinley statues at
and they had a massacre that wiped out
majority that we got people during there
in 1860 so I mean just and then McKinley
also eat although he was never there in
Humboldt County his actions but he did
well as president severely affected the
Native Americans throughout the United
States so in the 1860s McKinley of
course was fighting slavery as a member
of the Union Army for three and a half
years that's I think we both agree a
virtuous thing he was president for a
term in a very short period what did he
do specifically to hurt the weot tribe
that's the thing he wasn't he doesn't
have any significance to to the weot
people but we're the statues at is the
issue the statue where he is located at
in the arcade applause it was used as a
at auction an auction block for native
Native Americans especially for Native
American youth or we ought youth and
yeah I was immoral human trafficking era
well that's all true I mean I'm not for
that but that didn't happen obviously
during the time that he was president
because there was no slavery of course
by his presidency partly because of the
actions that he took his Union soldier
and so you can see that he had nothing
to do with any of that so why go to the
I'm an expense to take his statue down
I'm confined I'm sure there are people
who statues might be offensive but why
him
but the where the statues at represents
the human trafficking area of the weot
youth of that time and were the his
statues at represents that and so and
also after his presidency they the ox
the slavery went on after his presidency
it's just it represents an a bad time
for the we ought people regardless and I
think it's time for his removal of his
statue to put up something that
represents the we out people since that
is their ancestral land and that's where
they come from so just having anything
that I mean this is so mindless it's
hard to track I want to take this
seriously I mean your name for example
is Madison Madison own slaves should you
change your name well you should ask my
parents about my name I don't know you
can change it if you I mean look I like
your name I'm not attacking your name in
any way I'm merely saying that there are
certain historical figures whose
presence would be offensive I get it I'm
not discounting the idea of it but I've
asked you to explain and given you time
on TV to explain what specifically about
this guy
warrants tearing down a statue on behalf
of a people half of whom live below the
poverty line there are a lot of problems
you could be dealing with this doesn't
seem directly related to any of them it
seems like it a massive waste of time
when you can be improving the lives of
the we a community but you're not why
this is this is gonna I mean this is a
is gonna represent a healing process
with the removal of the McKinley statue
okay I mean the so do you think that
people will live longer happier lives
that I don't know the 17% of the we outs
who are unemployed will get jobs I mean
do you really think that maybe it could
be telling I mean the the healing
process takes a long time occasional
trauma that happens so it's time for
that that he's had he's had a good run
he didn't do anything wrong though so
crazy County nice to see you Madison
thank you